non so bene come descriverlo come gioco
però avete visto il primo episodio
sapete che non esiste modo di descrivere
questa roba quindi che la faccio vedere
basta secondo episodio di shell su cell
buona visione chi è stato con budino
gigante vieni mancava sta roba
senta signor budino le dispiacerebbe
mica darle ladini c'è una risata
stranissima è un coro tornare indietro
scommetti ma mi chiama 6 stealth quanto
un camion ma spiega c'è rimasto male
poverino grazie
qualcosa mi dice che non pacchi
incazzato no no no no potrà mangiare zio
no c'è un cartello no no grazie a forme
la sbrigo io devo andare indietro sicuro
entra lì dentro fa qualcosa
niente
arriva il di possibili alla ciliegia e
ciao qualche macchia che fastidio c'è
veramente giuro che domani vado a
comprare un pacco di ciliegie così me ne
mangio tra te e cestaro col nuovo sodo i
creatori di sto gioco quanta droga
cos'è successo tu sei cucchiaio noda in
testa merito posso portare ovunque vai
sono bravissimo mi hai sfruttato una
cosa sbagliata zio disputare l'altro
aipo avanti zio va avanti così perfetto
sfrutta l'altro sputa l'altro no
ascoltate un nuovo nuovo all'occhio di
bue va bene o esce cannavacciuolo
esempio a vedere da un pulcino quanto
frontisti guccini
[Musica]
va beh quanto a roma lì dentro sto tizio
essere un cappello e vabbè la mega
ciliegia dovrei prendono altro quella
lista
ma sei scemo ma già la amano e già
perché la mangiata scopre che non è una
ciliegia ma è una persona alla ciliegia
mangiato tra il contrario troppo vuole
nulla stringe
lasciami dentro la scia già me lo merito
[Musica]
in questo potrebbe essere un problema
perfetto
puoi riprendersi la ciliegia normale per
favore
[Musica]
il cappello ma no è più importante il
cappello della ciliegia va bene eccolo è
quello sbagliato mi va bene neanche
quello quanti cup era un condom quelle
un condom e niente ora non capisco di
cosa si sta per così anche i birds and
reverse mai il lancio incredibile ad
opere predare in corso beh mi sa che mi
sa che l'ho tirato troppo forte prova
bene riproviamoci zio ha rivelato ma
devo farlo cadere nella pentola a ok
penso di dover sfondare il muro se ne
tornò nella pentola
unica vuoi
ma allora io non sono conosciuto nel
mondo per la mia mira a questo te lo
assicuro
ma dai
quanta sfiga è difficilissimo salve c'è
un'altra pelle può centrare quella no
eppure l'ho preso e varrà qualcosa non
arriva un'altra va bene la pentola
volante ancora più difficile ragazze
porca vacca cielo quasi eccola è la
perfetta
ho fatto la puoi prendere adesso no
perché è andata via
[Musica]
il ragazzo avendo una crisi di nervi ve
lo giuro stavo qualcuno conosce i
creatori di questo gioco mi fate sapere
in un commento se stanno bene a ciano
anche la pagina twitter bene a vedere
veramente con il cuore ve lo chiedo
perché mi stanno malissimo ma tutto a
posto
no no perché poi ci uan cosa cosa
diavolo è va bene va bene o grazie a dio
incredibile mi raccomando mangia la
siria lippi che la perdi perfetto e poi
evitare di prendere la mia fottutissima
ciliegia quanto preso male su cell
ogni tanto compare il titolo è geniale
la geniale
questo potrebbe essere un po più
complicato del previsto posso entrare
dentro sto robottone gigante
vabbè a noi due pescarolo come faccia
tirati punta ecco
sarà ci sto neanche nella cabina io
aiuto non so se hai notato veloci
viaggiare su un monociclo occhio
sicurello cerrato 20 volte fa strano
daichii scarsa che ha capito tocca a me
la mia ciliegia mia hai vinto per la
ciliegia si è scappata se non se ne sia
accorto
eppure tu quindi va bene a questi
continuano a menarsi al esattamente
tutto questa ciliegie ancora lì ormai
non so più cosa dire avevo giuro cos'è
salve lei e lei è la cosa più bella che
abbia visto il suo gioco finora e questo
dice tutto
scusa adesso ti metto a posto promesso
doppio c'è la tua è il mio cappello io
tokyo facciamo uno scambio equo
no no no è l'occhio è l'altro ecco
roberto importante che io abbia la
ciliegia poi imprenditivo white
[Musica]
quanti acidi sono gioco quanti
e va beh cosa sto società dove sono
finito io ecco mi sta bene
prendi la prendi la prendi a premia ok
niente sospettato per un attimo bonanni
a niente
perfetto next level radio ma c'è una
radio c'è la doccia facciamo la radio
vediamo cosa c'è il radio maria
non sai come si accederà alla colletta
con lista è la mia ciliegia ma o dov'è
finita non ci sei nello specchio inserì
flash si sta benissimo è prova
[Applauso]
ok a cambia il mood estivo inverno in
base al cappello metti questo corsa sia
c'è il bottone rosso mi ispira
tantissimo non fa niente veramente a
ecco mi sembrava strano vuoi stare zitto
mi dai fastidio al tipo di fianco farlo
stare zitto ma basta tentare di mangiare
qualsiasi cosa lsd simulator lo sapevo
era un fungo allucinogeno l'avevo capito
rivali nel centro che è finito l'effetto
cappello normale e via
non posso provare accendere la doccia
vedere che succede
[Musica]
no perché io lo sapevo che potevo fare
la doccia giustamente chi è che non beve
l'acqua della noia ma poi ha previsto il
fondo povero fungo è la madonna la mia
pp fa crescere i funghi a dismisura
ragazze
ok il dato ha mollato dalla ciliegia
spinata che però non ti puoi mangiarti
punti tu sarai scemo quindi adesso non
devo fare altro che ritornare indietro
mette il cappello normale adesso non
ciliegie caduta prendi la adesso esatto
fatela rubare incredibile un genio lo
zio scappa all'innse cappella di scappa
da di scappata rischio pari esattamente
quello che non doveva succedere
[Musica]
vabbè arriveremo a una fine ve lo giuro
nave lo posso giurare vedremo vent'anni
ma ci arriveremo
[Musica]
e vabbè ma cos'è il martello di thor ma
lo zio menaye di menardi menarlo forte a
botta incredibile la vera madonna fatto
veloce e 2 cosa cosa sto vedendo due
erano di mail ho fatto un pinguino a una
certa io c'ero mazzi caso di bug e se
sta roba
bravo però non c'entrava niente in
confronto
[Musica]
qualcuno sa dov'è finita la mia ciliegia
ed ecco la lega bene ad estrazione
pedara dall'altra fa bravissimo nella
più totale disperazione perché non
riesco a descrivere quello che ha appena
giocato concluso qui l'episodio di
giudici c'è quello che minchia è volevo
dirvi che il blog non c'è stato oggi ma
ci sarà domani perché non so
organizzarmi con i video non so
organizzare neanche la mia vita
figuriamoci il mio canale youtube ci
vediamo domani con i blog e le episodi
del cha cha il continuerà nella
settimana questa che arriva ok quel i
ragazzi a vivere se non ci sono le
telecamere non esiste una statistica del
recidivo
lo smettetela entra così tanto non si
capisce una sega di quello che dico
prova da ragazzi
[Musica]